[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola hola
cómo están espero que estén muy bien
bueno yo sé que probablemente muchos de
ustedes les sea familiar esta imagen
se les es familiar todo en la película
todos vimos el triste desenlace de esa
película solamente de esa película ok y
bueno lo que les quiero decir es que si
precisamente todos recordamos la parte
donde spider-man desaparece todo causado
por el chasquido de tanos pero qué
pasaría si les digo que está nos no es
la primera vez que aparece en nuestro
planeta o en nuestra historia realmente
hace varios años este compadre de aquí
llamado está nos ha aparecido ya en
nuestra historia en la forma de este
otro compadre de aquí que se llama tomás
que se llama tomás ar maltés
malthus malthus hace muchísimos años no
me pregunten cuántos pero hace
muchísimos años escribió este pequeño
libro que se llama ensayos bueno primer
ensayo sobre la población en el que
malthus dice lo siguiente
conforme pase el tiempo es el tiempo la
comida dentro del planeta va a crecer
más o menos así y la gente dentro del
planeta va a crecer más o menos así
saben qué significa esto significa
peligro
entonces si efectivamente significa
peligro porque porque es obviamente
malthus decía que toda la gente iba a
sobrepasar toda la cantidad posible de
comida que pudiéramos llegar a producir
entonces independientemente de que todos
nosotros imagínense que toda la
población del mundo en ese momento
estuviera trabajando a marchas forzadas
todos íbamos a terminar en una en un
estado de crisis totalmente crisis
verdad y que la única manera de
solucionar esto era si la población se
reducía por cuando pues por la mitad lo
cual nos llevó a hacer el primer ensayo
de la población de malthus algo más o
menos así como lo han visto no entonces
sí efectivamente
maldad se volvió un meme de su época
pero bueno la historia nos dio la razón
la historia no le dio la razón a malthus
y lo que hizo fue básicamente mostrarle
el poder de la tecnología y mostrar que
con la tecnología la forma de producir
comida y alimentos y recursos para toda
la población iba a ser posible y así
como la tecnología le quitó la razón a
malthus la tecnología le quitó la razón
a tanos si un spoiler perdón muy bien
otra forma u otro caso u otra cosa que
ustedes han visto no se han visto este
meme anteriormente bueno si no lo han
visto pues es ahí está este en este meme
homero simpson primero que nada
encuentra 64 rebanadas de queso
americano en su casa en la noche digo
porque qué mejor cosa puede estar
haciendo las 12 de la noche trabajaba
con el queso verdad entonces voy allá
atrás están es medir si el señor bernés
tratando de robar el oso de peluche pero
eso es otra cosa entonces 'número
encuentra 64 rebanadas de queso y decide
comenzar a comerse las a la mitad de la
noche qué es lo que pasa o qué que por
qué decidió hacer esto
para ejemplificar lees esto les voy a
hacer una pregunta a todos y a todos los
que están aquí presentes si yo les di a
escoger en este momento entre un bote de
agua y un diamante que escogerían
probablemente escogería en el diamante
no porque a quien le sobra un diamante
ahorita nadie
muy bien claro pero ahora imaginemos que
les voy a dar escoger entre un bote de
agua y un diamante
ahí imagínense que estamos en el medio
del desierto que escogerían
es el bote de agua claramente digo mayor
lo escogería entonces
ahora pensemos que estamos en el bote de
agua pero que cada digo que estás el
desierto pero que cada cinco minutos yo
les voy a ofrecer un bote de agua o un
diamante
que escogerían
si cambia verdad probablemente en el
primer round es en los primeros cinco
minutos escogerían agua porque estás en
el desierto y al nuestro desierto que
pánico muy bien probablemente al segundo
round también si no tiene sentido
probablemente el tercero el cuarto el
quinto el sexto pero qué va a pasar al
séptimo
muy probablemente en el desierto pues no
es como que traigas una caja para llevar
ocho rebotes de agua y si la traes pues
qué flojera porque qué flojera cargar
una botella en la caja line de botes de
agua en el desierto que es lo que va a
pasar que para cuando te dé el octavo y
pides un bote de agua pues probablemente
se vote a vaya a pensar un poco más y te
va a cansar un poco más el noveno no se
diga el décimo el onceavo y así
sucesivamente entonces va a llegar un
punto ya ni siquiera en la pantalla este
va a llegar un punto en el que el agua
probablemente ya no nos va a satisfacer
tanto como lo hizo en los primeros cinco
minutos y aparte porque el ser humano
pues sí podrás estar el desierto pero
cada cinco minutos estar tomando agua
imagínate no te terminas el primer bote
y ya está estando el segundo entonces
está como que no manches que pasa que
probablemente para el turno número 14 ya
es un diamante porque dices oye
que esté en el desierto ya tengo agua
tengo diamantes y esto efectivamente no
lo ejemplificó homero simpson hace
muchísimos años estado que se llama la
paradoja del valor que quiere decir que
conforme dan conforme nos vamos
satisfaciendo más por algo
esa cosa va perdiendo un poco su valor
entonces llegó un punto en que teníamos
tantas botellas de agua que ya simple y
sencillamente no satisfacían sí y así me
quedé también entonces qué es lo que
pasó
homero simpson comenzó a comer sus
rebanadas de queso tenía 64 previamente
para la primera es cool no la segunda
pero para cuando terminó la número 64
muy probablemente se veía así muy muy
claramente se veía así verdad sí
probablemente estaba ciego y claramente
marcelo regañado pues por acabarse el
que eso es casa no entonces esta es una
una especie muy buena de paradoja del
valor y ahora este valor si no me creen
con queso se lo voy a ejemplificar
cuando muchísimo más padre un episodio
de 'bob esponja' en el que bob esponja
decide vender estas deliciosas
cangreburguer es de colores al principio
toda la gente le dice oye qué estás
haciendo porque estás vendiendo esas
cangreburguer de colores 'bob esponja'
pero bueno no se dan cuenta que
realmente esos cambios de colores
generaron que miles y miles y miles de
personas llegan a comprarlas esa es la
casa de bob esponja para el que no sepa
vive en un pequeño vecindario de
tres casas y bueno pues leyendo verdad
se le se le llenó todo el mundo quería
las las cangreburguer de colores de 'bob
esponja' y que pasó llega una escena muy
padre o esponja en el que bob sponja
pues empieza a vender todos esos
cangreburguer se genera dinero y genera
tanto dinero que le dice a don cangrejo
sabes que al principio no sabíamos qué
hacer con todo ese dinero tratamos de
quemarlo
tratamos de enterrarlo tratamos de
no sé hacerlo triturarlo o algo por el
estilo pero al final del día que
hicieron lo regalaron entonces
claramente eso nos muestra que el valor
del dinero conforme era tanto dinero el
que tenía uve esponja simple y
sencillamente ya no valían nada para él
ya no valía absolutamente nada y un
billete medio que porque obviamente
tenían billetes de bajo el agua un
billete más que tuviera pues realmente
ya no lo satisfacía absolutamente nada y
qué fue lo que pasó al fin el día pues
lo terminó regalando y la gente que está
la fila pues alguien te agarraba sus
botellas de sus productos sus bolsas de
dinero y corría atrás y se volvía a
formar esto es bastante bastante común
en el valor del dinero entonces las
cosas también pierden su valor y el
dinero también pierde su valor cuando
que cuando hay demasiado dinero
y también me quedé así
y bueno no obviamente 'bob esponja' y
los simpson y los avengers no nos
enseñan nada más estas cosas o no
realmente no es el propósito de ellos
enseñarnos estas cosas claro que a todos
nos ha pasado esta esta creo que todos
hemos estado en esta situación en el que
estamos al lado de alguien y estamos
pensando y de seguro estará pensando en
otra persona y la otra persona está pues
con el dilema existencial de si el rayo
mcqueen tiene un seguro de vida un
seguro de carro claramente es una
pregunta bastante bastante compleja y
bueno que nos dice esto pues básicamente
la persona que está al lado de alguien
más está haciendo un supuesto está
pensando que la otra persona está
pensando otra cosa dije pensando muchas
veces entonces pero por qué por qué
hacemos supuestos realmente los
supuestos son parte fundamental de
nuestra vida y para todas las cuestiones
más complicadas que ustedes se puedan
imaginar imagínense ustedes una no se
proyección del banco mundial sobre
cuánto va a crecer méxico o imagínense
ustedes una proyección del fondo
monetario internacional sobre cuánto
dinero debería haber
cosas por el estilo todas están hechas
pensadas en que nosotros cada uno de
nosotros que somos las personas que
interactuamos en el día a día y que
vivimos en este mundo el día a día
estamos haciendo algo tal cual como
ellos pensaron que lo íbamos a hacer es
decir hicieron un supuesto imagen si
ustedes que abren un negocio y deciden
pues pensar cuánto vaya a poder vender o
cuánto no voy a poder vender o cuánto
dinero voy a tener que regalar y bueno
pues estamos haciendo un supuesto los
supuestos nos ayudan al simplificar todo
lo complejo de la vida porque la vida es
demasiado compleja como para entenderla
en un solo número o en una sola línea o
en un solo papel entonces hacer un
supuesto nos ayuda a simplificarlo
trabajarlo y al final del día poder
entenderlo realmente no sabemos por qué
homero simpson estaba comiéndose todas
esas rebanadas de queso realmente no
sabemos en qué se gastaba o esponja el
dinero de la sangre guras de colores
solamente estamos suponiendo así como si
suponemos que están pensando otra cosa
cuando claramente el rayo mcqueen tiene
un seguro de carros no un seguro de vida
muy bien y bueno pues realmente que cuál
es el propósito de todo esto porque
tuvimos estas cuatro historias o estas
cuatro pequeñas anécdotas sobre los
avengers 'bob esponja' homero simpson y
bueno memes de internet pues porque nos
enseñan cosas y nos enseñan cosas más
que son entretenernos y realmente nos
están enseñando cosas sin darnos cuenta
de que nos están enseñando cosas estoy
seguro que más de un niño probablemente
pensó en vender una cangreburguer de
colores después de que había el piso de
esponja y estoy seguro que más de un
niño también pensó en desvelarse para
bajar a comer queso a las 12 de la noche
después de ver ese piso de los simpson
pero más que eso nos están enseñando
cosas sobre el valor sobre el valor de
las acciones que tenemos las acciones
que hacemos de las cosas que tenemos y
de cómo las cosas fácilmente pierden su
valor entonces esto es básicamente son
cuatro elecciones pero realmente el
mundo está lleno de memes bueno el
internet y pues el internacional el
internet detalles nueve meses entonces
cada meme y cada cosa y cada película y
cada acción nos está enseñando algo
total y completamente diferente
sin que nos demos cuenta entonces si
alguna vez quieren aprender algo pues
vean un meme muchas gracias y hay un
meme despedida
[Aplausos]
[Música]